hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game hopefully uh that will be
played by me I'm gonna play three plus
zero um in the game on leeches uh our
opponent is ORF ORF Cox uh and uh he has
the white pieces so I'm gonna play the
Scandinavian as I usually do and now as
the world cheers Championship is over uh
dingler and is the world new Champion uh
I know it's a it's a different world you
know everything is different the air
feels different the the trees are
different you know the flowers smell
different uh but we're gonna have to get
used to it and uh you know Embrace this
new reality so I'm I'm going for the
Scandinavian the same one that I usually
go for he plays Bishop to C4 I'm just
gonna play something like Bishop G4 or
Bishop to F5 uh let's play Bishop death
five Bishop the G4 looks scary but it's
really not
so let's Castle Queen side and he
castles Queen side as well okay
uh pretty pretty standard stuff and um
hmm
I want to try and exploit the position
of the bishop and C4 so I'm gonna play
E5
and now I'm gonna play the Queen to B4
uh looks odd but I am attacking his
bishop and his Queen and he has to play
something either either Bishop to D3
okay so he plays that
it's uh
newish move I I haven't seen
but it makes sense yeah it makes sense
uh
um
yeah that's not bad
it's not bad at all
hmm
we're gonna try this yeah I don't mind
this
or rather I shouldn't mind this
we'll see what happens okay let's just
move back
uh
I'm looking forward to taking the bishop
here okay I don't mind him taking that
pawn let's just capture the the bishop
here
uh yeah okay now we get a free
developing move in uh our Bishop
controls the light squares nicely uh
we're putting some pressure on his King
side okay of course of course he will
play that why not
um he wants to gain nice control over
this square but my knight is guarding
that so I don't really have to worry
there uh do I want to shift my knight
that's the question do I want to play
something weird like this no I don't
then G4 okay no maybe I do
yeah maybe I do
it's a weird move but maybe I should
play it yeah
it's a really weird move huh
something like Queen F6 Maybe
then Rook Cafe he doesn't have this The
Rook is nicely guarded I don't know
I have no idea
um
I'll just wait and see what he does
and if he doesn't do anything
threatening what is what is my plan what
is my plan
um okay obviously I could try and grab
some pawns but I'm not really okay he
disconnected
let the game you can claim victory
okay
uh
baby doesn't come back
that's very sad
even though I feel his position is
better
so we're gonna we're gonna have to play
another game
maybe he comes back if he comes back I'm
gonna give him more time uh you know
just so he can play
okay so no okay so he came back no
okay do I call the draw
hmm
uh he he seems to have some issues with
his with his connection
yeah okay let's call it a draw uh
yeah let's just quickly check
yeah okay so he is he is winning here if
he plays Bishop to D5 obviously I was
not expecting a move like a bishop to D5
uh but yeah for some reason I mean his
position is better he's not material but
I thought I could uh you know make
something work so obviously it's good
for me that he disconnected uh but I'm
gonna try and play another one uh maybe
maybe not not be so ambitious
all right so let's see
let's see who we get
[Music]
um
all right so Mr
zaharua from Ukraine and he is also a
leeches Patron so very nicely done by
him uh what do we how do we greet uh
Alicia's Patron let's greet him with E5
and let's go version C5 something
funky
all right let's go for okay so he goes
for this let's try let's try and give
some Pawns
okay so he goes for that
um
let's go here
um I don't know okay obviously that
doesn't work
but still
uh
let's go here
I don't think he was expecting that
or that he even likes this
let's go C6
C6 maybe Queen E7
put the Rook enter game oh he's gonna
Castle Queen side
I don't know about that looks uh
looks like something I would play so
that's why I I I I don't really have
faith in it
can we ignore that just let me take a
capture no no we can't yeah we can't
[Music]
um
yeah let's just go back if he pushes I
don't think that's an issue let's go
here
we're gonna push next all right so he
wants to play this uh we don't mind
you don't mind that uh yeah okay
it's fine
uh let's just take here
uh if it takes I have a nice in between
move so let's do that
uh and I can even not take the Knight I
can even push yeah so I waste as little
time as possible
alright so now he wants me to take this
way can I save more time no I can't
um
yeah okay
fair enough I will take the Knight I
will take it
and now we I don't know I kind of feel
my position is really strong
um
he's gonna play F5 of course I don't
want to blunder my piece so let's give
our Knight a square
okay
hmm
okay we're we're really doing poorly on
time so that's why our position is sort
of manageable because he really isn't
wasting any time
[Music]
this bishop is super scary
it's gonna play check Maybe
do we mind no no we don't Let's uh throw
in no we can take the queen here
this is uh a big blunder by him
it's a big wonder by him so yeah it's
very unfortunate
all right so now uh what's the quickest
way to win obviously this
um yeah it's very sad
but what are you gonna do
nothing to be done
yeah
yes indeed
he will still try something here okay
nice Checkmate here all right so um this
was a weird game and the first one was
even weirder where I was lost but okay
so far we're doing fine we're gonna play
one more as both of them were fairly
fairly quick games okay we are playing
against CPT North
so let's play an ic4 maybe we see okay
do we do we see an Evans Gambit for the
final game I hope we do I hope we do see
it there we go all right finally
uh I feel bad playing this because you
know whenever I okay
the the declined events Gambit
let's do this
it's not uh not as exciting but uh yeah
okay we can play it
we can play it uh not a problem let's
play D3
I actually have no idea how to play the
declined one and I I I rarely even want
to but yeah let's go A4
um
you know he probably captures with the F
Pawn if I take so I don't want to take
ah let's put a bishop here
and get our Rooks uh what are the the
finest swears for our Rooks okay so this
stays closed I can maybe play King H2
maybe put the Rook here and then maybe
Advance the pawns all the way uh so
let's try that
huh
all right so let's try that or maybe or
maybe
I want to spend too much time here
yeah let's do that
let's do that I hope for some sort of a
future D4
the moment it's impossible but uh
oh he wants F5 okay let's play G4
let's play G4 and maybe
okay I don't mind
I guess I don't mind I don't know
um
okay
very nice
very nice by him let's take now I think
it's uh
about the time we take and now he he
gets F4 okay so he won the F4 Square
very nice
very nicely done by him
yeah there's no good way to handle this
there really isn't
okay so I guess I have to give him the
the F4 Square
have to given the F4 Square I have to
play Queen here to keep an eye on
everything and then my queen is really
terrible
and he's better on time I'm you know I'm
hoping for some Knight to E3 to F5
action but uh
he's better on time and this Knight to
F4 move looks scary we'll see what
happens
if I can get the king out of this
diagonal and then you know just survive
at least for the moment should be okay
you might have some sacrificing ideas
like takes captures captures captures
here and then captures here for some
reason I don't know yeah he's gonna go
for that
he's gonna go for that because then
Queen G3 will be impossible he will just
take my queen as the F Pawn is pinned so
that's that's the unfortunate one so I
have to play this first sort of a nice
solution to going after his Queen
and now Captain G4 so that should work
yeah that should work all right so
capture here
uh if he really wants to play that F5
move but now I have um
do I have it do I have D4
yeah okay now we take
let's play a rook here first Rook here
first
uh this is uh
it's gonna be scary
[Music]
all right
I can't blunder the G4 Pawn I can't
plant blunder some sort of a check I
can't allow his Queen I can't blunder
Queen like this I mean come on
uh this is uh I have to play something
like this allow Queen H4 no he's gonna
play that what is he doing
am I blundering or is he blundering I'm
hoping he's the one that's wondering
um okay he's the one that's wondering so
that's uh
uh that's nice
yeah can't allow him to Checkmate me
have to play it like this and now he
might trade and go for some sort of uh
and go for some sort okay if he tries F6
I don't see him surviving this no
anymore
so that's pretty much game over
uh if Rook F7 okay now we win we're up a
full Rook uh does he have some sort of a
check or some sort of a Perpetual I
don't see it uh that's that's the stuff
and my father is calling me I know why
he is expecting some what did I just
wander up Perpetual because my father is
calling me
oh no
oh that's super sad oh no
why you do this Dad why you do this
he could have taken the Rook but then I
kept G6 no
this is super sad
oh come on yeah we're both low on time
but this is uh this is not fun
this is not fun at all I just have to
avoid a Perpetual all right okay so is
this enough this is enough
this is enough he's gonna play Rook D7
okay now we take and that's it we don't
care
all right
that was uh
that was very nice okay let's go here
try and Checkmate him if he doesn't want
to then we Checkmate him like this or we
just trade Rooks
both is fine yeah okay now he will try
to flag me but uh of course
uh having The Rook that's impossible all
right so uh almost dad almost got me but
we were able to survive this but I can't
believe I blundered that G4 Pawn
uh but yeah okay uh three games is
enough for for uh for one take
um I'll try to do some more if you guys
want to see as I really play a very
limited amount of openings like I played
the Scandinavian with black and with
white I play E4 but I would very much
enjoy learning uh a new opening like I
always wanted to be a sicilian player so
if you want to you know uh see me trying
out uh something or even some sort of a
Gambit or something you know do use
hashtag uh suggestion in the comments
and I will try to make a video like this
where I you know face some opponents
with
um with an opening of your choice so
yeah let's uh let's let's also try that
uh so yeah those were the games hope you
guys enjoyed it yeah okay the first one
my opponent disconnect the second one I
also well was very tricky-ish and this
third one was also very very disgusting
play by me but what can you do that I I
obviously I'm a disgusting player I
can't help it see you soon guys